let's go next to our caller from the
nine one nine area code what is 91 nine
North Carolina it's at me yes it is oh
hi David
wow this is cool I didn't expect you to
actually answer me
welcome we are it is North Carolina it's
in Raleigh gotcha
it's North Carolina it's in Raleigh very
um so um I guess my question especially
involving current events in both
Australia and and Iran after last night
yeah I was wondering if there was
anything that you could say for those I
guess I was wondering if there was any
there was any advice you had for those
who was who suffered from how do I say
this who suffer from eco anxiety and
world issues anxiety that uh you could
say to help I don't know I mean listen
here's the thing this is I I hesitate to
do this because I think that political
and civic engagement is so important
so I I'm saying this only take this for
what you want right but a lot of the
stuff that's going on around the world
if you tune out you're gonna be okay and
and I I don't mean this flippantly I
just I see so many people including in
my personal life who are just so
affected by the disastrous what's going
on with the environment the
embarrassment around the world that is
Trump I actually understand some people
who go hey you know what my life my life
span is limited I am just going to seek
the the most pleasurable and and least
difficult life possible I'm just gonna
focus on my day-to-day enjoyment I'm
going to try to tune out a lot of what's
going on like I I don't think that
that's good as a society but at the
individual level I get doing it you know
because it's it's getting so bad right
now and I'm not necessarily recommending
that you do that but I would understand
that if you did for your own well-being
I've tried I've tried that in the past
and I didn't know I'm more I'm I'm
- ace is trying to get more and I'm
trying to face this by getting more
involved in things going to more fluid -
that's but like speaking for speaking
out publicly about it but I see you're
not no camera we're not looking to UM
you're not looking to just feel better
you're looking to actually make an
impact I guess but I just don't know
yeah yeah I mean listen it depends on
what issue you know what you would do
for the environment would be different
than what you might do for local
government in terms of weather getting
more involved makes sense but that's
good I mean listen you you you know when
I say I understand people completely
checking out I don't think that it's
good and I think it's better for a
society you know if we all check out
then they get a free and clear path to
the hoop so to speak to use a sports
analogy so I actually think that it's
right that you want to get more involved
I would you know we'd have to talk more
about exactly how you would do it but I
I applaud your instincts because it
would be far easier at this point to say
I just can't do it I'm checking out no
I've tried that before and it just makes
the repeat it just makes going back to
it just makes going back to things even
worse a diet that I totally understand
well listen I appreciate that you want
to get more involved and let's you know
the first thing we can do is at every
level let's do the best we can in
November of 2020 there are local state
and national elections in 2020 we're
trying to remove Trump or trying to take
back the Senate they're City Council's
governorships let's take the next ten
months and focus electoral II and and
then hopefully the changes that come
from the November election will give us
four years or two years depending on
which office you're talking about to try
to make more change I think that's the
immediate plan ah all right thank you
thank you David
I really appreciate you answering this
for me appreciate the call thank you so
much and I hope to hear from you again